you see this world of New York City and
it just seems like shangri-la is just it
sparkles and glows and it's full of
endless potential but also no I'm does
eat along I'm a metalsmith in New York
City and this is my studio
metalsmithing became passion for me the
second I struck hammer to handle
[Music]
[Music]
it's extremely important for me to have
a vehicle in the city is that Subaru
Impreza I use this to pick up equipment
I Drive every morning commit to you I
also use it to travel to and from my
shows up and down the East Coast better
10 to 12 hour drive this card's just
along for the ride and I've been on a
pretty crazy ride the past six years the
life I had before moving to New York I
had a full time job at Duke University
of a nurse in the ICU I had a beautiful
little Crossman home I had found that I
was completely apathetic just
passionless and I wanted to change and I
wanted something that felt foreign I
wanted to be uncomfortable I wanted to
challenge I realized I had to get back
to my first love which is making
I didn't even really think about how
difficult challenging expensive or hard
it was going to be to learning model
slipping and make a living doing it all
I thought about was just do it I chose
to move to New York City because I
wanted to see what living in the city
would do to my work I love driving to
galleries that have my work so that I
can see how they put it on display what
I have in common with Subaru is creating
a quality product that you can rely on
that's going to work and it's going to
service purpose I don't want to put
anything out in the world unless I'm
absolutely passionate about it my past
experience as a nurse is intimacy with
body and form really influences the
pieces that I make because I think about
these pieces and how are they going to
to drape on the bite my knowledge of
anatomy and physicality that's what
really influences the designs I've had a
life that's practical and stable and
safe and now I've had a life that's
unstable and risky after experiencing
both versions of life I can't really do
anything now unless I'm absolutely
completely engaged
[Music]
you